John how are you good morning Dan I am
I'm here in LA finishing this thing up
all right you gave a lame excuse that
you couldn't be in the bracket challenge
because you acted a lot busier than what
you really are that you were involved in
the World Baseball Classic and you
couldn't fill out a bracket when we
really know the reason why Michigan
State's not any good this year and
therefore you couldn't go to the well
and bring Michigan State to the Final
Four maybe to a title game that's really
what it came down I mean that bet I
could see where you're coming from there
I can see there but you didn't you
didn't jump in you did jump in at the
end because you were guilted into
joining us because yes John you're not
that busy with the World Baseball
Classic well I mean I have been on the
road dan 430 out of the last 33 days so
I am more why I'm Road weary and I'm I
mean it i guess i've been listening to
the NBA thing if this i I could have
taken a couple games off you know for
this classics but I I didn't do it and I
did take off this year's I got admit I
did not put my best my best effort for
the bracket and I apologize i speaking
of pacing yourself in sports and when
you were with the Braves yet did you
have a four-man rotation one of the last
four men rotations in baseball well we
we didn't have per se a four-man
rotation although in April we went to a
four-man rotation only because there are
so many off days but we the four of us
pitched every five days depending on the
off days we didn't really we didn't use
the fifth starter a lot but today that
that you know that does gone right out
the window and so it's pretty much going
to a six-man rotation and a lot of
situations for these team which i think
is a you know i'm not i'm not a fan of
but the game's changed in a lot of
different ways so i'm trying to adjust
but you got guys who aren't playing
hundred and sixty-two games but here we
are saying to LeBron and steph curry and
you know some of the big names you know
we need you to play every single game
that's the obligation but is anybody
keeping track of Mike trout's game or
Bryce Harper's games in baseball no no
you know I think the only reason people
have kind of looked at it that way is
this seems to be this mass substitution
of sitting but I get it man that's did
you talk about a sport these guys are
the greatest athletes in the world and
they are constantly it's not like you
know there's a lot of resting that goes
on they play a ton of games I totally
get the concept that's life San Antonio
has been so good for so long they the
Popovich just kind of deals with it in a
different way but I get it you know I
mean I look I can I can barely sustain
my over 40 league you know repertoire
once every other two weeks so I do have
to ask you a question on that
continental tires questions that's
commercial how long did it take you to
make that shot notice the third shot
third shot yeah it's impressive yeah and
why didn't you show me this was at a
different studio why didn't I see the
golf simulator that was at the Barclays
Center in Brooklyn all yeah but I they
the Nets wanted a tutorial on how to
shoot so I came down there to help them
and then then we shot a commercial as
well so I i was able to do two things in
one they actually asked me to play and I
said I can't but uh because I can't
commit to all these games I'd have to
take some games off but I mean you've
got a golf simulator in erie oh yeah I
didn't want any show me that we win you
didn't they wasn't in the commercial
it's a basketball commercial so I know
that well why don't you get high but I'm
talking about your golf simulator that
you know is right a different studio
yeah you were in New York I i have a new
york studio and then i have one here and
then one in Los Angeles okay I just just
hope anywhere to hold on oh no I
wouldn't do that to you no absolutely
not if I gave you the Cubs of the field
who you taking
well I mean the Cubs certainly are going
to be one of the favorites right but I
would take the field just because it's
so difficult I don't care how good you
are is so difficult to repeat I mean
you're getting everybody's best shot all
the time and so as dynamic as the Cubs
are going to be if you press me again
said I'd take the field just because
there's so many good teams of the elite
teams there's enough teams that can pick
them take care of business he's John
Smoltz will be part of the world
baseball classic that'll be coming up
tonight USA versus Japan and then the
winner gets Puerto Rico tomorrow night
championship game so where Joel Madden
said why don't we have a best of three
with the winner of the World Baseball
Classic against the world series champs
what do you make of that yeah I mean
there's a lot of ways to people to try
to figure out how to to make this you
know even better or condense that I just
don't think you're going to get a team
that just finishes a long season want to
compete against against the best I've
always said that think you've heard me
say i would love to utilize the all-star
break shut it down for a week and have a
condensed you know maybe the top four
played two games kind of what we got
here in LA admit season or play USA
versus the world within our own sport
there's a lot of people that weigh in on
how this thing gets done every four
years and and having covered it from the
beginning to the end you see a lot of
different countries that are all in for
this thing and their emotion is unlike
anything we see during the regular
season and that is what they're trying
to do and represent their country and in
an incredible way we have a bigger pool
you have much more selection process and
sometimes we focus on who's not here
instead of the guys that are here
whereas the other countries don't have
as big a pool and they get a probably
higher percentage of their players to
play for it so you know I I'm a big fan
of showcasing our international talent
because there's so many of them I would
love to see it I don't know if it'll
ever happen but I'd love to see it
during the all-star break if you were
Tim tea
those advisor what advice would you give
it ah man you know I think the one thing
that people don't recognize is the
incredible impact this guy makes around
the world forget the country and forget
our United States I i I'm and I'm in awe
of what he does off the field so
whatever he does on the field and
whatever people you know want to be
critical of them that's their right my
advice would be keep making an impact
you're making outside the field and
regardless of what people think whether
you ever gonna play the game or not
somebody wants to part of their
organizations and they're they're
valuing what he does impact lies around
the players he's around so I'm never
going to be after just before never
going to be one that suggests what
somebody should or shouldn't do based on
the percentages of success I do believe
the client John what he's got off the
field do you believe this is real on the
field that then he once you get to the
show and he's going to be in low a ball
oh I believe what he's trying to do is
real whether or not he's he's able to
succeed is irrelevant because somebody
is giving him that chance you know if it
was if it was a year-long campaign to
try and do this and nobody was knocking
at the door and give him a chance and
I'd be a little different but I mean
somebody's giving him a chance so I
think that part is definitely real Rick
Ankiel got a book where he talks about
Vinnie had to calm his nerves and he he
drank before games and big games you
know match up with Randy Johnson did you
I mean how common is this well I've
never seen it but uh I wouldn't think
that's too common if if more people have
had the opportunity but I can I could
certainly appreciate yes his honesty put
in the book I had to actually drink
myself to when you were pitching for the
Red Sox though just
I can't do it I don't play it I hope in
you know what for the sake of a lot of
my I'm glad it wasn't that long right so
at least you didn't fall into like this
horrible habit because you know it was
painful watching me go no I totally get
that it was only eight starts John it
was it was yeah it was for the sake of
everybody that that needed to not
continue I understand could you get
tbell out right now no no I couldn't I
couldn't get anybody out right oh I'm
behind come up selling it come on down
it's it's it's it left you okay okay out
of maddox glavine your you who has the
best stuff right now i'll probably
despite what it looks like funny wise
and Holly Maddox did you see the bit
that he was doing where he was throwing
BP with Kris Bryant yes oh that was I
thought it was excellent I was awesome
because he you know he's Maddox he's
just making it move a little bit and you
can see Bryan going oh man this guy's
got a little bit of something there it
was it was absolutely it ranks right up
there with her there chicks dig the long
ball I mean they're sneaky and when they
can get it done but yeah Maddux and
Glavine and then me as far as I it just
doesn't work my shoulder doesn't work
anymore that was good while it lasted
though Jonny yeah yeah absolutely you
know you can have more of this sense of
humor on displayed tonight the world
baseball classic that will be on the MLB
network with matt bacak Eurasians is the
one of the original voices of the XFL
Matt fest gershon that is correct in 15
usaw against japan at nine eastern on
the MLB Network I think we'll get this
one under four hours well good luck with
that John I'll talk about that thank you
John all right I said that's John Smoltz
Hall of Fame pitcher yeah he made it
seem like he was really busy when Prince
he goes against Smoltz says he's too
busy with the World Baseball Classic I
go no Michigan State's not any good if
Michigan State was a top five team no
he'd have a whole lot of time for this
the Dan Patrick show we
morning on audience